I also love gemstones crystals and
whatnot
you need a tourmaline what's a
tourmaline
what it does is it looks like a piece of
coal but when you put it in your pocket
all the negative energy that goes to you
the stone pushes back against them but
I'm doing that naturally what's it
called a tome or what tourmaline I might
be a human tourmaline yeah you got your
perspective
be happy don't you want to be happy
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you guys
really excited to be here so a lot of
things to talk about and looking forward
to the Q&A so really the context of what
I want to talk about tonight is
entrepreneurship through the lens of
parents and children obviously you know
as I get to sit up here and look around
the crowd it's it's a lot of fun to see
the mix of the audience going so high
and low in the age group and and it
really speaks to a lot of things that
are extremely near and dear to my heart
you know what's really interesting about
the day and age that we live in right
now is entrepreneurship is cool
entrepreneurship is a viable option it's
a path that a lot of people are choosing
aspire to choose and that is wildly
different than what it was when I was
the age of a lot of the youngsters in
this room being 43 and growing up in the
80s and 90s for my you know school years
kid years there really was only one
option which was go to the best college
you can and that is the leverage point
to the job and I'm sure for a lot of
people here call it 38 and older that
makes a lot of sense that was our
framework what's interesting about that
framework was so much of my happiness
and so much what I talked about is
predicated on the circumstances of my
upbringing which were quite humble being
you know a Russian immigrant and going
to Queens and Jersey and really like
grinding out that lifestyle and number
two just remarkable parenting you know I
am completely the byproduct of really
really great parenting which more than
anything else
allowed me to not be suffocated by the
fact that I was an atrocious student and
allowed me to lean into that I had
hustle you know it's crazy to me to
think back and think about all the
teachers and all my friends parents who
told me I was going to be a loser or I
was not going to be successful even
though I was making
$800 a weekend as a 12 year old slinging
baseball cards and and and I guess it's
a lot of ways there's a lot of things I
want to touch on tonight including the
reverse of everything I'm saying I think
one of my great beers currently is that
entrepreneurship is cool and it is a
viable option and I believe that 90% of
the people that sit in here and think
they're going to be an entrepreneur are
not going to be successful at it because
it's ridiculously hard and not that I
want to say that to crush a dream I want
to say it to give people permission to
fail and then to adjust once they get
older or or even for the parents in here
who decide to start an entrepreneurial
career and instead of a job and when it
fails you know I really am scared that
entrepreneurship takes the place of a
Harvard degree that I grew up with there
is no exact right way of anything this
is you know if there's anything I want
to get across tonight it's self
awareness you need to figure out who you
are not try to be like somebody else and
then more importantly and in parallel
because I'm gonna jump back and forth of
things that seem like contradictions I
think one of the things that we have to
really talk about in the business world
and definitely in the parenting world is
actually meaning it when we say that
happiness needs to be the North Star
something I'm outrageously sensitive to
the current state of the human race and
definitely the context I understand
which is a lot of different cultures but
definitely the American culture there is
way too much unhappiness in our society
and it's predicated on a lot of
different variables but the biggest one
is or not the biggest one but some of
the things that dramatically stand out
is over valuing other people's opinions
being delusional the amount of ambition
coming out of people's mouths that does
not match the work ethic that they're
putting in is the funniest thing for me
in society the amount of people who I
people understand what they're saying
it's very hard to be a millionaire the
top 1% earners in America top 1% starts
at four hundred thirty thousand dollars
a year if you make four hundred thirty
thousand dollars a year in America you
are in the 1% earners in our country yet
people throw around millionaire like
that's just the beginning cuz I'm gonna
be a billionaire and so you know to not
you know what I want you know this is
fun for me taking advantage of the
context of this room given kind of this
beautiful setting and this amount of
people in it you know I'm I tend to like
this kind of environment much more than
some of my bigger speeches and more than
let's say five people this is a very
sweet spot for me and so I'm excited
about tonight
I really how are we doing QA are we
gonna be running mics or we can be
setting up mics to do we know from the
back because I might even go to it a
little bit earlier because I have a
funny feeling a lot of you know where
I'm gonna go with a lot of this stuff
and I want to milk as much interaction
as possible and even seeing how you guys
are collectively reacting I will
definitely be doing that are you gonna
run mics you've got the questions from
the audience can I break the system a
little bit and play great all right so
I'll be I'll be taking questions so okay
so I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna play
here a little bit my talk about a couple
more things but we're gonna go into you
know when you ask your question I'm
gonna ask you to go loud because I'll
repeat it so everybody hears it but look
I mean I think this is a very special
time in in the world and I think on you
know it's really funny I always talk
about don't be in the middle don't be
half pregnant I pull from opposite
directions I have cook you know a lot of
what is interesting about me is I see
very very different people associated
with my message people that genuinely
don't agree on a single thing
politically or socially because they're
hearing different things for me and I
bounce around and I'm been thinking a
lot about it you know parenting
philosophy entrepreneurship philosophy
obviously political philosophy like we
are pulling further and further apart
from each other people are pulling in
such
opposite directions yet I I feel like
there's so many merits and so many
different nuances to points of view and
I just think that we've become so
one-dimensional and so absolute I think
we have to start talking more about
allowing people to change their mind I
think if we make changing your mind
something that is put on a pedestal
instead of demonized you know I think
that would really help us you know I
talked about recently I think I tweeted
I looked at it very carefully of how it
was interacted with that changing your
mind is the ultimate strength my you
know it's funny I was with my dad the
other day I used I would change my mind
all the time I changed my mind all the
time down and he used to drive my dad
crazy but that's super old-school and he
kind of thinks like if you said
something you know then that's it for
life you know and and I just remember
that quite a bit growing up building the
business the wine store that my dad had
and I helped build to a big level and
you know he's like three weeks ago you
said that we had to put liquor in the
front and I'm like I changed my mind
I listened more to the customer I tried
the liquor in the front I don't like
what it did were changing and I think a
lot about that now with my content which
is why am I so comfortable with trying
things I posted a video yesterday that
was upside down on Instagram I don't
know how many of you saw it and and and
maybe and then a couple days earlier I
made a video where I just said like this
post like 58 times in a row and I've
been using this hashtag in the two posts
that you know always be testing and it's
really my way to give you a nod of
giving you permission the like like like
video did okay the upside down video
yesterday did not do well and that
excites me and I'm excited to spend more
time over the next you know year or two
of trying things completely left field
to hopefully inspire people to you know
what I'm so unbelievably concerned about
for everybody in here who's creating
content whether on YouTube or Instagram
or other places is you've become so
obsessed with the number associated with
the post that you're not actually been
putting out any
or what you want to put out you're
putting out what you know is gonna work
and that leads to real insecurity there
are people still showing way too much
skin because they know that does better
there's people that are flexing when
they can't afford to because they know
that does better
there's people regurgitating other
people's quotes because they know that
this but I mean just it's not it's not
working and it's and it's going to
continue to decline in value and I'm
sure if you know anything about me my
number one thesis is producing content
that scale right now it is such an
opportunity I I couldn't you know I'm
gonna beat this horse until not only is
it dead but it's buried and I throw a
bomb on it you know this is this is the
for everybody in here who's nowhere
close or not at where they want to be it
is absolutely the most cost-effective
way to start the process to whatever you
want it is about producing content
producing content at scale for as many
platforms as possible so many people in
this room could have all the things that
they wanted to happen on YouTube and on
Instagram for the last three and a half
years and has not happened actually
happen if they get serious about tick
tock for the next six months you know
I'm already seeing it I'm already how
many people here have posted their first
post on tick tock in the last two months
raise your hands how many of you of the
hands have just put up actually got a
lot of views on a post that you would
never expect it it's a high percentage
and this is what happened on Twitter and
YouTube and Facebook and Instagram in
the early days and obviously tic TOCs
not early days because it's musically
then reformatted tick tock but the scale
of users on it and the attention it has
is not still filled with enough content
for all the contents out there there's
still more attention than there is
content which is why on day one anybody
here get real views on their first
actual post by any chance you did like
some of the people are getting this and
they're like email you know obviously
I've been on it you know this is what I
do if you followed my career or if you
want to know like every one three five
years I get hot I've been analyzing
for six months a month five months I
feel firm and I'm ready to cheerlead a
new platform because I think it's
crossed the chasm of my filter just
saying okay this actually is a good use
of your time period and so this is what
happens in my career but I've never seen
a platform given how it got big and then
got bought and then got big I've never
seen a platform reward creators with so
much free attention on it their first
post ever and so back to a lot of like
the micro things if you leave with
anything like whether you're 9 or 99 I
think tick-tock needs to be taken
serious because it has the potential to
be completely mainstream for every age 4
years from now it may not it may go the
route of social cam or vine but if it
goes the route of Facebook and Instagram
you're gonna get so much more dividends
and the other thing everyone's always
like Gary I don't wanna waste my time
we're like I don't have enough time the
upside is so much greater than the time
especially if you have a lot of ambition
again this is what it continues to
baffle me Gary I want to build something
you I want to leave my job that I don't
like and I want to start this side
hustle around Star Trek or or soccer or
cooking but I don't have time to post on
tick-tock - I just will never be able to
figure that out unless you're working
and you're with your family 20 hours a
day 18 hours a day you do have time
you're just not willing to sacrifice the
time or the energy that's needed to
actually have a life that is based on
your own terms we are something a word I
have not used historically that I'm
starting to use is sacrifice I'm
fascinated by people's inability to
sacrifice luxuries Gary I don't have
money but I buy $7 Starbucks you don't
need a $7 coffee right you don't need a
$12 scrunch
like you don't need an $80 hoodie you
don't need it you're more than welcome
to have it but please don't come to me
and cry that you don't have money for
Facebook ads when you buy dumb [ __ ] and
so I think about that I think about it a
lot and so these are the themes I'm
thinking about I think it's never ever
ever ever been a better time to build a
business or to build something for
yourself than right this second it has
never existed this is these right now as
we're in here this is the single best
time ever because the Internet continues
to grow in its scale which means
nobody's actually stopping you the
Internet's the offset to bad behavior by
humans it is
there's no gatekeeper there's nobody
who's making a prejudice decision a
sexist decision nobody stopping you from
signing an account on tik-tok or
LinkedIn or Facebook or YouTube and
making nobody it really is the great
equalizer I was having a conversation
with somebody able to weekend at the
football game and they're like man it's
crazy how many of these female rappers
are popping Meg the stallion cardi you
know everything everyone's like a lot of
them are winning sweetie I'm like it's
not confusing the industry only allowed
one woman to be on top 15 years ago when
they had control now the internet has
control there's no confusion this was
always the way it should have been and
so but but and I think we can all agree
but politically there's a understanding
of suppression and things of that nature
people are confused the internet isn't
playing within the ecosystem that we
live they're not and so to me that's
inspirational that's amazing it's crazy
to me that we all have these they're
bats by the way you may be confused
that's my story the way I present myself
the way I roll the education I had the
way I curse the the ideas I have the
establishment never believed in them no
internet no me Wall Street Journal
wasn't gonna be writing about me and so
I think that
if you leave with anything tonight that
the second you actually truly start
realizing that if you don't have the
success you want that that's you the
second you actually genuinely stop
blaming anything and the second you
start taking on 100 accountability is
the second you start getting happy for
real what I'm really excited about
especially with such a young crowd is
thinking about the young entrepreneurs
in here who I want to talk to to me the
fact that you're even here whether you
want it to be here or your parents
dragged you out you know is something I
think a lot about you know I think you
know I'm so grateful for
entrepreneurship you know one of the
things that one of the things about
starting a YouTube channel and not
having a lot of views or trying to sell
some slime and only send it selling zero
you know on your Shopify one of the
things that the kids in this room don't
understand yet is that no and losing are
their best friends 100% I unfortunately
and this is just the truth kids in this
room you're growing up in a time where
grown-ups want to stop you from feeling
losses and pain more than ever because
truthfully are we've now lived through
seventy years of prosperity and our
parents can actually spend time worrying
about that stuff instead of putting food
on the table but not to get too heady
here if for the kids in this room the
number one thing about starting a
business or trying to build a profile is
that you're gonna lose a lot a lot of
people are gonna leave comments that you
stink and you should stop and you're not
good you're gonna try to sell something
and nobody's gonna buy it I think back
to once the story I never tell that I
just got inspired to tell in this room
just remembered was I actually sold
stuff door-to-door a lot more as a kid
than I remembered I just thought about
it the other day I should just find
things in my house that might have not
even been mine
and I should just walk around Edison New
Jersey ringing people's doorbells and
asking them if they wanted to buy it I
was who do you want to buy this weird
t-shirt for this pencil
and when you wouldn't you're selling
ridiculous stuff that nobody wants
outside of the one person every 50 homes
they just thought you were a cute kid
and gave you a dollar you just got a lot
of nose and and one of the reasons I
think so many people are struggling and
are unhappy in their early 20s as we're
coming into a place where people are
hitting their 20s that were parented of
a generation that tried to overprotect
and and I think losing is awesome
because you deserved it means somebody
was better than you and that's good for
you to know cuz that's a real life
that's how it's gonna be and I think
getting somebody to say no is awesome
cuz that's real life it doesn't mean you
suck it means what you tried to do right
now didn't work and I think that we have
to have a much bigger conversation
around that and I'm happy a lot of you
are listening to it right now because
it's very real because I will tell you
kids and parents for that matter that I
set up here tonight extremely happy
because I was losing so much and got so
many nose as a kid
cuz now that I'm a grown-up it doesn't
scare me
and unfortunately for a lot of grown-ups
it continues to scare them they cared
about what kids in high school thought
about their dress they cared about
opinions and they were overprotected and
it made them incapable I really believe
in the zoo animal thing we go to the
Central Park Bronx Zoo right now and
release those animals in their natural
habitat they're dead in ten seconds and
I think we have to be very thoughtful
for the parents in this room especially
you brought their kids tonight
you have to let them lose no vacant fake
environments are destroying their actual
confidence
[Music]
it's the great disservice of parenting
to eliminate merit and the truth from
your kids so I really like
entrepreneurship for that you know my
mom didn't micromanage she let me live
which means the system said no to me a
lot I did a lot of card shows that I
didn't do well on I had a lot of bad
things happen you know when I was 13 40
year old dudes were ripping me off you
know cuz they just imposed their old man
will on me and scared me like all sorts
of stuff happened all of which allow me
the great luxury to be in front of you
tonight
so really ultimately here's what I would
say and then I'll go into Q&A because I
think I'll bring the most value I
desperately need you guys to leave here
understanding how ridiculously lucky we
are to be alive during this era this
internet thing is no joke no joke and
and I just and by the way for everybody
who gets um trillion followers and makes
it and I mean Justin Bieber YouTube like
it's now been a while since this has
been happening and working I think for a
lot of this room you may not go on to be
Bieber or build a YouTube channel that
makes 80 million dollars selling toys
but the real conversation that isn't
being talked about is I do believe
almost everybody in this room is
uncomfortably capable of producing
$100,000 a year business if they put in
a lot of time and a lot of effort and
have skill whether that is through
making a channel and having brands
subsidize that or selling stuff or
starting a product and and I hope that
everybody who watches this that's not in
here or even the people in here realize
that that's a big statement that's a lot
of money it just is and and I say it's
so simply but it's not simple at all but
the fact that you can in a way that you
never could before
is remarkable and I think all the people
you look up to or you admire or you
watched build real businesses or real
influence on these platforms they're the
preview not the anomaly and not
everybody's gonna have my natural talent
or work ethic or the chips fall the way
they did but I don't I want people to
love their game the way I love it not
yet the accolades or success that I have
because the happiness is way more fun
than a byproduct and I know a ton of
people who are unbelievably happy and
make 49 thousand a year and I know an
enormous amount of people who are deeply
unhappy and sick who make seven million
dollars a year and something I've been
saying a lot and I want to say more
often there was always that joke that
people talked about like around always
valuing money and they talked about
I'd rather cry in my Ferrari right and I
thought that's saying always pissed me
off right this notion that okay you're
crying you're deeply unhappy and the
Ferrari versus a Toyota is supposed to
be some sort of variable there it's it's
such insane bad talk everybody should
aspire to be smiling in their Toyota if
you find out and understand yourself and
you put yourself in the best position
and you happen to have talent and you
put in a ridiculous amount of work then
you might be able to smile in your
Ferrari and that's amazing too but these
are the things that are running through
my head and I appreciate you having hear
it tonight thank you
[Applause]
so let's do some Q&A who's got a
question
yes ma'am stand up and ask away oh you
have a mic nice I'm gonna try to play a
little bit yeah we'll do the best we can
try your best
well bounce around this this young lady
right over there stand up I love you too
what's your name my name is reka and
first I just wanted to say thank you so
much for like everything you give to us
through all your content that you
provide and to like the whole community
that you built thank you um my question
is okay so just a little background
about me is that I have a jewelry
business and I design and I sell on a
website awesome um and a23
awesome so I wanted to know how you
separate like your personal life your
business life and your social life and
everything that comes outside the
business and then separate it when it
comes to once you're in the office or or
even a step further like when one thing
happens to your business how do you like
get out of that mindset and move to then
on to the next thing without being
distracted and staying focused trying
you know some days something happens in
the office and even though I'm going to
like a family holiday dinner I just
can't get over it because I've haven't
figured out the solution yet for me I've
got a lot of experience and I also to be
frank and wildly not that concerned
about money slash my business I'm really
not I just don't know what else to say
and that's not because I've done well I
was that way when I was grinding and
building you like it just I just don't
put business it's my greatest passion
and it means nothing to me
I'm being dead serious because I know
that if I built a billion-dollar
trillion-dollar thing bought the Jets
and my family dies in a plane accident
I'm not a happy person
so perspective really helps me it's if
everyone's alive I'm good
I struggle with taking people's judgment
both cheers and boos so that's good so
I'm just kind of cruising but the
biggest but the answer I'm giving to you
that I think will help you is not
necessarily where I'm at at 43 years old
with 37 years of practice in my mind
it's where you're at and to me the
answer is don't over judge yourself if
you can it's only one day if you have
something going on in a personal
relationship that screwed up your day at
work because you couldn't get going
that's okay that's not only okay if you
screw up a day it's okay if you waste a
week it's all soaked if you waste a
month my biggest thing is why are we
over judging ourselves or just all
living out here you know
I mean it's so much more like easier to
say like oh it's just perspective but
like on the daily when things are
happening and I know you're middle of
doing something I'll say for your baby
who's who do you love the most of the
world good who in your family
pick one you're very politically correct
cool every day make in the mid like
literally once a day genuinely sit there
for five minutes and make pretend one of
them got shot in the face I'm being dead
serious with you every single day I
almost I said this today earlier I
probably once a week to four times a
week sit there truly in the shower on a
flight when I wake up some people
meditate right
some people workout right to deal with
whatever anxieties or thoughts they have
I actually sit and truly try to convince
myself that I have lost one of the five
most important people in my life and
that is the biggest thing I do that
leads to the biggest happiness I have
like what you didn't sell enough
earrings today like seriously though
people lack perspective it's actually
remarkably easy if it became if it
becomes the way you see the world like
what what like we have completely lost
perspective as a society do you know any
people on earth have it way worse than
you
billions I just want to remind everybody
we're sitting in Manhattan right now we
have completely lost perspective so it
is easy for me because I practiced that
perspective because I grew up hearing
the stories of my mom losing her mom at
five my dad losing her is that of 15
them being in the Soviet Union I
remember sitting in a studio apartment
with a family members and having nothing
like I
no it's very easy you're 23 you're
winning
I know I have your a quote on my phone
that says you could go hard for 10 years
and and do everything wrong and get up
and so it doesn't mean that you're not
trying to do the best you can and what
have you but you have to quantify that
emotion you know my biggest thing to you
is you have to make sure that you
eliminate judgment where everyone's
losing is there worried about what other
people think everybody everyone's losing
that game because the reason I can deal
with losses every minute is I don't care
what you're saying about my loss I love
this when athletes get to this level the
reason they're doing well is they don't
care what ESPN said or what you said on
Twitter they're playing you're in the
seats and that's how I think about
everybody I'm playing what you're gonna
say I had a bad idea or didn't work I'm
playing and so I think that may help you
to like at this day and age nothing is
private it's like everyone knows
everyone's business that's not true I'm
minding my show you guys know nothing
about you know nothing about my family
what what people put on social media
that you pay the consequences thinks
they know about you even though they
don't that means you're worried about
their opinions no I mean I personally
good so then go back to your question so
I can help you because I'm enjoying this
what you know what what's you know
what's easier said than done for you
know cuz I feel like what bothers you I
feel like I constantly I'm getting
distracted by by just being 23 and that
and that life outside of this mixes it's
just so there's so much ahead but like
you feel like you're missing out no no
no not no not at all but like you feel
that like there's a lot of time but
there's not like you had you're in your
20s you have all these good years and
it's very like I'm - let me tell you
about your 40s they're [ __ ] good
I get it I get it and you'll appreciate
this and I'm glad we did this
that's why I talk about patience yes you
know because what you're actually saying
is you're impatient and that's okay no
no I'm not okay you are but that's okay
go ahead I'm patient but now it's gonna
sound like I care what people think I
feel like everyone is like always in my
business like oh when are you doing this
and when are you doing that why don't
you why don't you basically I'm patient
even though I'm patient no no it makes
you impatient because you're valuing
other people's opinions you just
literally made both of my points
literally you said I don't care what
anybody thinks
and I'm patient and then your answer to
it was people are my business saying
[ __ ] which makes me impatient let's move
on it's the first off I want to say it's
a small world I grew up in Flemington or
some ergo before that so love it
Somerville wow you grew up in Somerville
and Flemington and for all you hardcore
New Jersey connoisseurs both of them
have a circle which is very rare in
Jersey that's annoying but so my dad's
actually been following your content
before I even knew about you and he knew
you before you when you were the wine
guy and you know so I'll be I'm gonna
embarrass him but he's like oh he
doesn't know what he's talking about
anyways now we're starting a farm and
there's a lot of vineyards that are
popping up in Hunterdon County and yeah
kind of struggling the Union Hotel it's
in like really bad district yeah so I'm
trying to see what I can do for the town
and I've stayed loyal
I actually got kicked out of high school
for something I'm not gonna talk about
here I basically like stuck up to there
like Super Nintendo might go ahead kick
me out I'll go to North Hunterdon and
I'll still get my diploma and you're
gonna have a bad name when I make
something of myself and you know
audition for Shark Tank I've met like so
many people like David Meltzer came out
to one of our events I do a van
at Microsoft at the time Square and even
before I started all of that came do avi
and I took a picture in Instagram like
all right guys I need this to blow up so
I was trying to meet you and you're like
I'm sorry I'm busy with family but is
this an emergency I'm like uh not really
tell the truth yeah so like even meeting
day like it was just kind of crazy I'm
like because he was talking and my mind
instantly went to you before he even
mentioned you and I'm when I went to
meet him after I'm like I'm sorry I'm
gonna talk back there this whole time
but that's just like been such a huge
inspiration for me it's like I'm just
saying up my story more so because like
I'm living proof that I actually was
able to get somewhere you know starting
out with a clothing line watching
Taylor's video of like 20 something year
olds trying that and you're like what
are you doing different so that made me
think even more you know what's really
great about you saying making something
is just how early you are in it hmm you
know people a lot of my friends or
people they get frustrated with me when
I talk about buying the Jets and they're
like when when I when they asked me when
and I say things like 25 years
they're like so disappointed and for me
it's like so remarkable mm-hmm like
coming here with nothing and not even
being able to own a Jersey to live by
the Jets at 68 years old that's an
all-time accomplishment
people are so impatient you know to your
point like it's real like to me I'm so
excited because you feel accomplished
and yet
you literally are about to live for more
full lives just the sheer amount of
damage that can be done like that back
because I want to put this at rekha in
your mind like you're literally very
likely I know you could get hit by
lightning but it's very likely that
you're gonna live for more full lives of
what you've already lived and when you
start putting in that perspective you
know that's why I say things like that
because it helps people slow down one of
the places I'm spending a lot of time
right now is on people that are 60
because if you're 60 you grew up in an
era where 60 was like where people died
when you were 18 and 12 and things that
nature yet it's likely you have 30 more
years so you're acting like you're
wrapping it up and you still have like a
real chunk
you do that's very real and so I think
humans really struggle quantifying time
and it's funny I just said some I used
to do this all the time I was so amped
you know it's funny I so see it with
lack of patience because my ambition was
so high so I can respect where that
comes from from a lot of people and I
used to do something when I first got
into my dad's business I was like three
years in I was already crushing and I'm
like oh I've only been doing this for
three years and in three years
I'll only be 28 hmm you know I'd get
excited and then I have like you know
you know seven years into it at 29 I was
like man and I at that point I really
already made it at some level for the
family and I was like oh in seven years
I'm only gonna be 36 and even to this
day like it blows my mind that I'm
standing up here and I've only been in
my career all my careers for 21 years
you know and for me to say from this
moment in 21 years right I'll be 64 and
that's young there's a lot you can do
and and now I'm starting it here at 22
I'm starting with a liqueur so you know
what I mean so I just it's I'm glad you
feel that way which triple excites me
because women started yeah I know
like I I make websites and I get like
90% there and then for whatever reason
you know the other 10% like just never
quick so cuz you got bored yeah it's the
same reason you and I sucked at school
or hated school whatever you were
whatever was you were breaking the
system yeah and that comes out of
boredom hmm ya know like I have wanted
to be like a singer at a young age and
my mom like kinda like yours she sat me
down she's like that's not realistic
focus on what you could actually
accomplish you know so I I was an
immigrant to move to when I was two
years old so it's just thanks for coming
to much thank you yeah
[Applause]
hello Gary hello name is Ross and I
waited a long time to say hi to you
thank you I watched you for the last
eight to ten years and I now AM
co-founder of an education company here
in New York City and around the country
and my one question to you is and that's
nothing having problems getting sales
like schools all over right here in New
York City Ola boroughs they have our
program it's called the web guys program
okay and we teach kids entrepreneurship
and we give them tools to create their
own companies online completely free of
charge in the public school system
understood my question to you though and
it's been racking my brain what how
would I use social media to target
teachers and principals and staff of
schools not necessarily that I don't
want to target kids I got it you know by
but by creating content for them on
LinkedIn and then running ads against
people that hold those jobs that's a
good idea thank you
and also how how would you frame and
this is a problem I don't struggle with
like all the time but I teach kids every
single day and I have a staff of 15 to
18 people that also I hire as teachers
how would you frame entrepreneurship to
13 to 15 year olds in a classroom
setting what would be the best what do
you think you know I I think it's it's
interesting the things that are running
through my mind is number one making
them realize that entrepreneurship is
more like sports so that would be
something I would tell kids I'm like hey
kids we're gonna talk about this but I
want you to know this is like sports
meaning I could sit here for the next
hour and teach you how to play
basketball
I can show you what a jump shot looks
like the rules you know what some of the
best players did about it but then we're
gonna go to the court and some people
are just not gonna be good at it like
and entrepreneurship
only plays out in real life not in a
classroom so I wanna a that would be the
first place I would start because
there's nothing about the rest of school
all that maps to the reality of
entrepreneurship right yeah so that
would be one the other things I would
talk about you know probably I would
start talking about the lonely in the
southern now because I think that's
something that we don't and didn't talk
about a long time that a lot of people
are struggling with what really sucks
about being an entrepreneur is when you
lose you can't blame someone else it's
really fun to work at a company because
when you stink you blame the boss when
your company fails it's your fault
and so accountability I would talk a lot
about accountability not being able to
hide and you know I would talk about a
by a lot of mindset stuff and then I
would put them in the field and let them
sell lemonade well we have them create
like little apps and companies within
the classrooms and they have to market
it to the rest of the school yeah I mean
I love that but I think I think as you
know that's a little contained
environment and it's nice it's great but
I would I would I would interject some
of the bigger truths for the ones that
go on to actually do it awesome and is
it a possibility I can take a photo with
you it's yeah we'll do it at the end oh
sure let's keep it going
[Applause]
don't worry we got time I see that I see
the emphatic hands will get to you I see
you guys over there
so first off I'm on the moon right now
because I'm talking to you and I'm
literally like 10 feet away from you yes
so this is insane
so I'm actually I don't know if you
remember but I was a kid that you kind
of you know roasted on Twitter
come on and so yeah so I'm I'm the Nick
Anderson kid that was like hey can I
intern for you this summer and you're
like yeah what would I say I was like oh
yeah what what you're like when and I
was like oh the summer Oh what's and
then you said like oh what's T red you
had I said hit up d-roc yeah and then I
was like what's this email and that's
when I got excited and that's when he
said when you want to intern for me and
can't figure this out for outer face yes
so and that was probably one of the most
important reality checks of my life Nick
you know what's super interesting about
this story this is so amazing to me
because and I'm gonna play here with you
a little bit because this is really good
because I really admire you because we
continued the conversation later
and then you email me which is in my
inbox that I rock this is super fun for
me too because I'm so behind on email
but I'm flying to Miami tomorrow I'm
like you know what I need to catch up on
email and literally when I thought that
today I was like okay my book publishers
in there this is literally what went
through my mind a couple hours ago this
is so fun to meet you in person I was
like okay my book publisher reached out
to me in my inbox they want to give me a
new big deal I should probably find out
what they're offering and I was like oh
crap that Nick Anderson kid is in my
inbox because I told him to email me
after we talked on on text Nick there's
an even more interesting part of this
story so I tweeted that out as you know
and I remember because your name was
Nick Anderson I was like you know what
I'm not gonna black out the name
sometimes i black out the name but I'm
like that's such a generic name like
Nikki Anderson the three-point shooter
over to magic and a bunch of other
there's a lot of Nikki Anderson's so I'm
like I'm gonna put that out it actually
got picked up in the advertising
rat age correct yep I didn't know about
that till the call of Andy and adage
took a really negative approach of the
way I handled that and we're basically
trying to tell me that I'm a bad person
for doing that
and I understand and now you are
actually the human involved in it and
you thanked me behind the scenes and now
you're standing in it saying it's one of
the best thing that's ever happened to
you right because it gives the ingenue
'ti you talked about the ingenuity of
being able to find an email address it's
also a complete and actual real-life
example of what I'm talking about in the
first 10 minutes of this talk which is
Pat age decided to take a snarky point
of view on me and try to paint me as a
bad guy when what I was actually trying
to do is bring you value we live in a
world right now where everybody wants
everything over coddled and then it
leads to kids being depressed because
they're incapable ah you took it the way
ninety percent of people took it which
is you're happy it happened and I'm
completely commenced that it's the kind
of thing that's gonna change the way you
do things going forward in a positive
way I meant what I said I wasn't saying
there was no tone of like you're a loser
in your idiot there was you know my
team's hard core we go hard and if like
you can't find d rocks email you this is
probably something you want to like
understand as a prerequisite I do want
to put it into context like I was at
again I was on the moon when you to be
replied to me so it's like oh my god and
the good news is like trust me I'm not
so overly worried about like that makes
sense to me if Randy the Macho Man
Savage texts me in 97 I would have lost
my mind so I think I think nonetheless I
I just want to give the room context
because it's crazy that this is
happening when it's the living proof of
what the first 15 minutes of this talk
was about so keep going right so so I
just wanted to kind of touch on a little
bit before it so I wanted to do a little
bit of a plug so well I had my college I
go to Nikolas College and I had some
freshmen but before that I was impacted
by cancer in my life I had
several people in my family and my best
friend's father passed away her freshman
year of high school so I went to Nikolas
college and I I actually joined one of
his Relay for Life teams is by the
American Cancer Society and I came to
Nicholls and I realized there wasn't an
event there so I decided hey you know
what I'm just gonna start this from the
ground up
I went door to door I got to over 200
signatures I actually so we did this
thing - you're gonna [ __ ] love this
one so we did this thing called suck for
a buck and don't mind the middle there's
a lot of kids in marketing marketing we
would vacuum people's rooms for $1 love
it so I would go and say and I want to
get a GoPro or something on my chest for
one of these days that I do it I say hi
would you like to participate in suck
for a buck mm-hmm and oh my god good
people it's just awesome so what we
would do is my roommate here Brian Brian
McLaughlin by the way wink wink so many
times just so busy knows what's
happening here prime McLaughlin is
mcLaughlin McLaughlin is also an agent
at Vayner Sports the same name just not
this one yeah yeah of course you know
maybe one day that's awesome right so um
so long story short we set our goal for
10,000 and we we actually had some
people that administration that said hey
you know what you should lower their
goal to 7,500 yeah and we furnished said
nope not doing that hit 10,000 10,000
two weeks before the event we raised a
15 hit that the day before the event
raised over sixteen thousand five
hundred and to date we've raised raised
over $40,000
[Applause]
and that was even before I met you
so now it's 400 million now it's
literally all of the money so so all the
money's right yeah so um and I'll saw
just cuz I know there's a lot of you
know I just want is there is there a
question it's okay if there isn't what
just yeah well I would if you would like
if you have any sort of like time cuz I
know it's really like maybe after we see
the kind of chocolate I will definitely
email you on this flight tomorrow and
like we're gonna offer you an internship
that was a real conversation we had you
may not take it
so
[Music]
so we'll we'll have time this summer to
talk thank your uncle your uncle let's
go to more
yes you stand up I apologize brother
give me one sec I'm gonna bounce around
you'll be next
go ahead yep huh yep I'm putting you yes
[Applause]
hi gave me how are you
I'm miss self-love I have a podcast cuz
you told me you start a podcast on
anchor it's about helping people heal
from their breakups anchored by FM /
breakups is my podcast I love it okay
this is my shirt I see it I won 6-5 so I
have a question about LinkedIn okay so
my podcast is personal
yohko length in its business so how do I
promote my podcast when a business site
like LinkedIn I really don't know how to
just post it post it LinkedIn is not
business linkedin has now become
Facebook okay like yes LinkedIn has the
component of recruiting but the content
in LinkedIn if you watch it carefully
looks more like Facebook five years ago
there is more business content but
LinkedIn has completely crossed the
chasm to be a general social network
when it comes to posting on LinkedIn and
so you should just post it there thank
you thank you thank you
let's go before we go before we go to
that dude I want to go to this kid
because he was next hi so I have a
question about starting a business I'm
trying to star sneaker resale I was
wondering what the best way to get into
it is sneaky reselling business so
sneaker resale is super easy because you
know are you looking to build a platform
are you just trying to sell sneakers so
I think platforms hard especially in a
world of go and stock ax and eBay like
everybody wants to build like the uber
the stock acts like you know to me
flipping is easy its grinding its
hacking its it's figuring out the
website culture it's figuring out
Instagram culture it's figuring out
staying in line for four-and-a-half
hours
but the quite to me the question is if
you're just reselling I think you know
the answers now it's a job really just
about bleeding and putting it you know
going if you're looking to build
something I think it's a very difficult
time to compete on platform unless
you're raising five to ten million
dollars you know because the cost of
entry now in a stock X goat you know
sneaker cotton there's so much everybody
wants to be the platform where people
flip sneakers not to mention you BAE
gets an uncomfortable amount Instagram
direct only so that's my point of view
on those two you're welcome
hi Gary my name is Kai I'm from Vienna
in Austria and I just bought one week in
New York and I have to see you I'm glad
thanks for being here to you and my
question is I was wondering have you
ever been so highly positive or when oh
what was the point in your life that you
realized that positivity is the [ __ ]
game yeah yeah I've always been very
very positive but I do think it's a DNA
trait that I share with my mom and you
know so yes I think that comes natural
to me I think I think I'm starting to
get to the point in my life where I'm
also really fascinated about the advice
I gave to the first question about why
was I so scared about losing family as a
kid I've been thinking a lot lately
about a week the only reoccurring
nightmare I ever had in my life when I
was 7 to 9 of this was just I had it a
lot which was we would go back to Russia
on a flight and the plane would go down
right and I'm just really thinking a lot
about it I'm thinking about what made me
so scared you know why did I love my
parents so much like all those things
and and what did that do to my
perspective and why did it put things in
perspective and you know I didn't
realize being happy or positive as a kid
was a business advantage but I
definitely believe that without optimism
you can't be an entrepreneur right it's
all it's like you have
believe like because it's super hard so
I do think optimism and positivity are
incredible ingredients but I think
people have to be very careful because
the other thing is I'm extremely
practical and lack delusion and being
optimistic and positive leads to
delusion for a lot of people this is
where self-awareness and accountability
really matter you know just saying it
isn't gonna get it done
and so yes positivity is the absolute
game but so is practicality you got it
you got it
[Applause]
hi Gary how are you I'm great my name is
Cindy and I am here because my son was
awarded tickets by your team first in
line I love that thank you you're
welcome
two things I have one question first of
all I love acupuncture that's what I do
I also do antique auctions I have an
auctioneers license but that's not going
so great okay that that's just kind of
slow yep not much with auctions my side
hustle which I want to become my main
hustle is channeling psychic readings
okay and so what I'm trying to do is do
Facebook lives for free so I can give
value and so actually total a couple of
people hear about them and so is there
anything else I could do just to kinda I
wrote a book but I have an idea I think
you should do it for free in real life
okay somewhere you know doesn't get you
arrested
you know yeah and I think you should
film them okay if people allow you to
and I think that's the content you
should put out okay and I totally agree
with you so thank you and then and then
if you think about and a lot of you know
this and I think a lot of you've seen
the Gary Vee content model deck and if
you haven't you should look for it once
you film it then you post products
produce it contextual to LinkedIn then
you take a clip and put on two you never
know which piece of content really
starts the process but I
I think that would really work because
then people can see it exactly exactly
one more thing please I also love
gemstones crystals and whatnot you need
a tourmaline
what's a tourmaline what it does is it
looks like a piece of coal but when you
put it in your pocket all the negative
energy that goes to you the stone pushes
back against them but I'm doing that
naturally what's it called a tome or
what tourmaline I might be a human
tourmaline let's say I'll get one but
I'm gonna give you a real preview I'll
send you one I will take it and now me
to give you the preview thank you
no no let me give it to you okay I will
100% lose it within 48 hours do you know
that the biggest reason I don't wear
jackets is because I lose all of them I
lose everything except my wallet and my
phone because I always I'm touching them
because I lose everything so thank you
so much thank thank you very much my man
come in right in a corner - he knew who
Nicki Anderson was so I was hoping he
was gonna have a question how you do it
Gary I'm well per your my name is Manny
digital I have a couple podcast but I'm
mostly fatherhood's being one of them
I'm here with the fatherhood's lit and
fatherhood is lit crew I see 40 they
know that man I saw him so so my
question to you is you know just given
the context of podcasts yes in sports
cuz I have one that's about basketball
okay my conflict is being audio first
yes and not really finding a place for
videos just quite yet just because it's
it's so ominous to me to have to do the
audio piece use clips to push everywhere
and then take the same toll with with
video I know it sounds like an excuse
okay that's not necessarily remoted in
order to scale and try to get the
listenership up it's just content and
guests to keep doing what I'm doing yeah
but I I think a couple things like
you'll love this like it's like ready
how do you become a better basketball
player you you Brett
you practice the reps right and so for
me the way to build awareness for one's
show is practice the reps but I want to
give you all the best moves by not
putting out video clips and images
you're not developing your left hand
gotcha got it make sense another
question for you
damn that was good if you understand if
you really understand basketball that
was one of my better ones what what size
of you shirt shirt medium I got you
black got it I'll rock it and I will
rock it I will support and that's by the
way this is the other way you find
somebody that you know will probably
rock it you know that's gonna get
attention and you get 800 more let me go
back to guests
you should DM every single person that
is in the top 1000 of your green guests
and three are gonna say yes and that's
gonna give you leverage I say keep more
MORE right right Larry Bird only made
the league cuz he did a lot of shooting
Magic Johnson literally every morning
before the bus came in literally shot a
thousand shots as a kid that's real life
it's real life
what's up Garrity how you doing I'm
James from father is lit hi no think I
know you for a long time I know man I've
been jabbing since we've been doing a
fat startup and I got my son with me
over here he is a it's gonna be 13 and
he's been um he's been living off of all
the jabs right where now he's getting
all the fruits of my labor but it's not
the money it's the perks how do I teach
him not to pimp himself out for the free
stuff and actually get some money so so
I think he you know you teach him by
first of all you still have an
uncomfortable amount of time to ask like
for the money you know like before we
start worrying about him this is really
important to me how old are you you know
the fact that your tonality is that
resigned to the fact that all the
jabbing and the aka for everybody
doesn't know what we're saying
giving you've done that you you ran out
of time you know so I think the way you
teach him is by you doing it by showing
him you know and I also think the
biggest thing that you need to pay
attention to because I know you well is
this sect I know you welcome which means
I like you and I know you're a good guy
but I don't know how you were jabbing so
I don't know this about you I think one
of things that I want to make sure
especially when people start looking at
my framework and they're like you know
it's give give give and then ask I'm
watching a lot of people that are trying
you know they tagged me in it and I
think people are very confused by giving
I think people think they're give and I
don't know if this is what you're doing
but I just want to go here because it's
coming value to everybody and it may let
allow you to think a lot of here are the
reasons why people are good at giving
and then get sad that they didn't get
here are the reasons number one they
literally didn't ask some people are
actually uncomfortable with selling
which is amazing nothing wrong with that
means you need to hire somebody who
sells you know number two they weren't
giving they were manipulating there are
so many people that think they're giving
but they're giving
with expecting I mean people were all
helping me look Gary I gave you gave me
what you didn't give me you rolled up on
me and handed me something that I had no
interest in so that you could then ask
me for two hours of my [ __ ] time you
didn't give me
you manipulated me so you know this is
again because I know you're a good guy I
don't necessarily think that but a lot
of you were doing it subconsciously
you're actually not bad people at all
you're just so hungry for what you want
you don't even realize that you're not
giving you're setting up your ask that's
why I work I work because the content
I'm putting out is giving I could care
less about anything that happens after I
don't need that that's I don't monetize
my audience that way I'm not looking for
anything from you
and at anytime I even get close to it
it's in the form of something that you
may you wear sneakers so if you think
mine look good I'll take it over Reba
you know you drink wine but I don't want
you to buy it if you don't you know and
that's why I like those kind of things
versus a mastermind for 30,000 a month
to teach you more you know and so you
know I think you show you you teach them
by showing you know there was a great
quote that always really stuck with me
mainly because I work a lot and that I
fear the time allocation to my kids and
it spoke about it was a quote of
something like my father showed me how
to live he didn't tell me how to live
that's what I think you need to do
because you got so much time
[Applause]
what's up Gary luck here how you a man
really well so I got my three boys here
I see good looking crew so me and the
missus we have to complete we got here
and two complete different separate
roads not even close
yep she has a typical Sarina story the
tiger woods were her father drilled in
her since she was a five years old and
that you're gonna be a singer song line
you're gonna be a singer-songwriter 16
years old boom side major record label
successful singer-songwriter me I'm the
opposite son of immigrants that came
here you're not gonna do it you're not
gonna do you're not gonna do it more
else than wins but I'm here now and they
were telling you you couldn't succeed or
the world was the world respect keep it
didn't have the aperture understood so
now we're at a place where those ELLs
are in our past they're in the rearview
mirror and we feel like we're in a great
place now but the common denominator for
us that we both didn't go to college
okay so for us we we wanted to give them
the best chance for success so we're
doing you don't think that's college
no one's well we're doing the opposite
now we're like you know what it's not
worth the struggle you shouldn't have to
struggle as your mom did you shouldn't
have the struggles I did so we're gonna
you're gonna go to this school you're
doing that and now we feel like where's
the balance so teaching your kids this
is what you have to do give me the best
opportunity but you know this is a day
most cliche thing ever right like
parents always want to give their kids
the things that they didn't have but
that often is exactly the thing that
makes them not be able to do the things
we want them to be able to do so what
are you in a city your kids when they
say well first of all let's get real
serious about this all three of those
dudes are wickedly different you know
what I mean like they just are so one of
them should go to college and do that
one of them should like the first thing
I don't think about kids in a master
thesis I think about one two three so
the number one thing I think we all need
to do is especially kids in that age
group is we need to watch the parenting
is a game of listening not talking
it's very cute that the two of you came
up with this master thesis of what you
want what you really want is for them to
be happy right and so I think you need
to be thoughtful about that and watch it
now you ask kids that age what makes
them happy it's like candy and doing
nothing you know you got a guide but I
think I think you can't put you
shouldn't put entrepreneurship on a
pedestal you shouldn't put school on a
pedestal you should put your ears on a
pedestal and really watch and listen to
them the number one what am I gonna do
I'm gonna desperately try to put my two
children in a position to love their
process the way I love mine and if that
comes in the form of they look at daddy
success and they want to save the elks
in Peru you know and go that route then
I'm and that and they're passionate
about that I'm fired up I'm not gonna
paper it or [ __ ]
I'm being serious you're not gonna save
the Elks in Peru wearing a [ __ ]
$50,000 watch you're not gonna have a
fancy New York apartment you decide to
save the [ __ ] Elson through your your
your fulfillments coming in heart not
cash well you're gonna be your biggest
advice if they decide to follow in your
footsteps oh I apologize what's gonna be
your number-one advice like you're
number one like like protip if they want
to say dad I would do what you want to
do what you do I'm gonna say go Mazel
Tov you know I mean look my kids even
from day one are already in a better
position because I plan on a gift not
giving them money you know but I plan on
giving them an opportunity like and when
I when I say that I'm not gonna be a
hypocrite my dad let me come into his
business but my dad didn't give me the
business I built my dad's business for
him and left with nothing let's just one
more time drill the story home for
everybody who's looking for a [ __ ]
excuse walked in my dad's business at 22
worked every [ __ ] day until I was 34
built it from 3 million to 60 million
and left with nothing
started over why did Boehner media start
in buddy media's conference room because
I had no money so that's what I'll do
you want to come and work at whatever
the hell I'm doing that I'm cool you
know but I'm not gonna undermine all the
employees in there and just put you on
because your last name's Vaynerchuk you
want to be in the music business I'll
call the number one person to let them
work and then when I hang what I'm
talking to them like listen don't put my
kid in a fake environment if they're
good cool if they need to be fired
better better I don't I don't want my
kids to make money I want them to be
happy do you know how unhappy the
unbelievable amount of 34 year olds that
have a senior job right now at some
company cuz they know the mom asked for
a favor they feel like losers so then
they buy things to make them feel better
that means nothing we need to start
having the real conversation in our son
I'm actually very comfortable with it as
you can tell and I think it's because
I'm willing to deal with the reality of
it instead of the ideology of it I don't
have those thoughts I am the macro
thought you guys have which is you love
them and you want them to be good but
like what process they go through
I don't put what I went through or the
counter to what I went through on a
pedestal not Harvard not
entrepreneurship is good then is what's
interesting to me who are you right now
at this time do you know world are gonna
live in you don't cuz nor do I got it
it's a listening game cheers thanks
Cheers
[Applause]